- [Instructor] Let's say that
we have two pumpkin catapults,
so let me just draw the ground here.
And so the first pumpkin catapult,
let me just draw it right
over here, that's its space.
And then this is the part
that actually catapult the pumpkin.
So that's what it looks like.
It holds the pumpkin right over here.
That's the pumpkin that's
about to be shot away.
And what it does is once it releases,
I guess someone presses a
button or pulls a lever,
the pumpkin catapult is going to release,
and so this arm is going
to turn a certain amount
and then just stop
immediately right over there.
And then that pumpkin, that
pumpkin is going to be released
with some type of initial velocity.
So your pumpkin is just
gonna go like that.
So this is our small pumpkin catapult.
This is our small one.
But let's say we also have
a large pumpkin catapult.
Let me draw that.
So our large pumpkin
catapult right over here,
similar mechanism.
But let's say its arm
is four times as long.
So, that looks about four
times as long right over there.
So this is the larger one.
The large pumpkin catapult.
Let me make sure to draw the pumpkin
to remember what we are catapulting.
And then it will go through
actually the exact same angle,
you go to the exact same angle,
and then let go of its pumpkin.
And this is gonna be a very useful video
because you will find yourself
making many pumpkin catapults
in your life. (laughs)
And then it will let it go,
and you will have some linear velocity.
Now we know a few things
about these pumpkin catapults.
Let's say the small pumpkin catapult,
the radius between the
center of the pumpkin,
center of the pumpkin
and the center of
rotation right over there,
let's say that this is r.
While for the large one, this one is,
this distance right over here, is four r.
We also know the angular velocity
while this thing is moving.
So we know that the angular velocity here,
let's say the magnitude of
the angular velocity is omega.
It would actually be negative
if we were to write it as a vector
'cause we're going in
the clockwise direction
because that's the convention.
But this right over here
is the magnitude of the angular velocity
and just to make that tangible for you,
let's say that this is
two pi radians per second.
And let's say this thing,
while it's in motion,
it also has the same magnitude
of its angular velocity,
so this thing right over here is also.
The magnitude of angular velocity
is once again two pi radians per second.
So my question to you is
how would the velocity,
the magnitude of the
velocity of the pumpkin
being released from the small catapult,
so v sub small.
If I put a little arrow on top of it,
we'll be talking about velocity.
Since I didn't put an arrow,
we're talking about just
the magnitude of velocity.
You can think about this as the speed.
How does this compare to v sub large?
We have the same angular velocity
but we have different radii.
Pause the video and see if
you can figure that out.
Well, the key thing to realize here,
and we've seen this in multiple
videos, is the relationship
between the magnitude of angular velocity
and the magnitude of
velocity, linear velocity.
The magnitude of angular
velocity times your radius
is going to give you the
magnitude of your linear velocity.
So for the small right over here,
we could write this as v small
is going to be equal to omega.
These are the same omega,
that omega and that omega is the same.
In fact, we don't even
have to know what this is.
We could say v sub small is equal to omega
times our radius, which is r.
And what's v sub large going to be?
Well, v sub large
is going to be equal to that same omega.
So I'm talking about this
particular omega right over here.
So it's that same omega
but now, our radius isn't r, it is four r,
so we're talking about, so times four r
or if we were to rewrite this,
this would be equal to
four times omega times r.
Four times omega times r.
And what is this right over here?
Omega times r, that is the
magnitude of the velocity
of our smaller catapult
or the pumpkin being released
from the smaller catapult.
So just like that,
you see by having the
same angular velocity,
but if you increase your arm
length by a factor of four,
your velocity is going to
increase by a factor of four.
And so you have the magnitude
of velocity of the pumpkin
being released from the large catapult
is going to be equal to
four times the magnitude
of the velocity of the
pumpkin being released
from the smaller catapult.